what if I told you I knew a way to dodge
taxes on a chunk of your paycheck or how
about an investment opportunity that
will never pay a penny of taxes on the
growth no matter how big it gets sound
too good to be true no we're not talking
about some offshore account in the
Cayman Islands this is the amazing tax
shelter of the IRA a government created
program designed to incentivize you to
save more for your future self in 1974
Congress wanted a way to incentivize the
country to start saving for their own
retirement and rely less on government
programs or company pensions their
result was the creation of the first IRA
the I stands for individual meaning you
don't get to co-own an IRA with someone
else and it's not dependent on a company
offering it to you like a 401 K the R
stands for retirement meaning you
promised not to withdraw the money until
you reach a certain age and the a can
either mean a count or arrangement
according to the IRS contrary to popular
belief an IRA isn't an investment itself
with a set interest rate or statistics
it's a holding cell for your investment
of choice an individual retirement
account can be set up at nearly any bank
or investment company and can hold
investments like mutual funds stocks or
ETF but an IRA doesn't have to be
individual retirement arrangements allow
you to apply the same tax benefits to an
investment like a piece of land or a
small business some folks have even used
this arrangement to tax altered dairy
cows a car wash and a habanero pepper
farm as long as you play by the rules
you can get pretty creative about what
you choose to invest in IRAs can be
broken down to two primary styles
traditional and Roth the traditional IRA
is the og IRA when you're going
traditional you're allowed to save up to
six thousand dollars a year or seven
thousand dollars if you're over age 50
and as long as you meet the criteria
money you saved into a traditional IRA
is tax-deductible translation the more
you save the less taxes you'll owe this
year and since you're paying less taxes
you have more money to potentially
invest in your IRA essentially it helps
you boost up the amount you've saved
every year and as the years go by and
your girl grows you don't have to report
the growth on your taxes but when
retirement arrives and it's time to pull
the money out the amount you withdraw
gets taxed as ordinary income as well
business you qualify for some special
variations of the traditional IRA the
first is the SEP IRA SEP stands for
simplified employee pension and can be
ideal for self-employed people the SEP
will allow you to raise your six
thousand dollar funding limit to the
lesser of fifty six thousand dollars for
25 percent of your compensation that's a
huge potential tax deduction each year
but beware if you have any employees
you'll probably have to fund their IRAs
at the same rate as your own and if you
work for or own a small business the
simple IRA is kind of like a traditional
IRA blended with a 401k available to
companies with a hundred employees or
less the six thousand dollar funding
limit is raised to thirteen thousand
dollars and offers a savings match
incentive to workers usually a three
percent matching contribution so whether
you own or work for the small business
the SEP and simple can help you level up
a basic traditional IRA then there's the
Roth IRA the cooler younger brother of
the traditional IRA making its debut in
the 1990s and named after senator bill
Roth the Roth IRA flips the tax benefit
instead of getting a tax deduction on
the income you put in now the capital
gains interest and growth can be
withdrawn tax-free in your golden years
with no limit this is super attractive
to younger investors since their
investments can rack up so much compound
growth over their lifetime there's a
potential boatload of taxes they can
avoid let's say you started maxing out
Roth IRAs six thousand dollars a year
every year starting at age 25 and let's
imagine that money gets invested in
index funds that grow at an average rate
of 8 percent per year if you did just
that until you reached 65 you have
around one point six seven million
dollars under ordinary circumstances
whenever you profit from an investment
you need to pay taxes but thanks to your
arrangement with the government your
Roth IRA hooks you a big time in our
simplified example your gains account
for one point four three of your one
point six seven million dollars and
assuming you own a fifteen percent
capital gains tax on those gains you'd
normally be on the hook for over two
hundred and fourteen thousand dollars in
taxes but thanks to the Roth that number
is Europe a couple important things to
keep in mind when investing through an
IRA first you can't touch the money
until age fifty nine and a half or
you'll get hit with taxes and a 10%
early withdrawal penalty though there
are a few exceptions to this rule like
paying for college or buying a home and
contributions or deductions might be
limited or eliminate it if you and/or
your spouse are working or have a 401k
or other retirement plan through your
job and even non-working spouses can
save into their IRA and they choose
so which IRA is right for you
luckily you don't have to limit yourself
to only one many people have multiple
IRAs as long as the total investment
doesn't exceed your yearly cap the
factors that might make a Roth
traditional set or simple IRA a good fit
are unique to you their age your income
your goals speaking with a tax
professional and a financial planner
about your situation will always be a
safe bet when deciding which IRA to
house your investments of choice they
can help you make sure you play by all
the rules of the arrangement and don't
overlook anything the one thing's for
sure the advantages of saving into an
IRA early and often are truly too good
to pass up
and that's our do sense thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description if you would like to
support us on patreon do you have any
other questions about how IRAs work ask
us in the comments
[Music]